and then I just became random I just
became one of the boys and you see that
key of navigating around the ways it is
so I think it's very true why do you
think it's okay in society for
what's the same manner of trash but it's
not okay for men to say women or [__]
even though it's more true I think they
can okay no way women do you think on a
public platform if yeah you have a
podcast do you want on your podcast and
just said modern women are [__]
wait but is that a generalization right
but but women but women generalize all
the time they say they're afraid to walk
alone at night I think I think women
call themselves [__] in different ways
so they call themselves sugar babies
they call themselves but we're not
talking about the women I'm saying like
why is that okay in society because it
means that you have to accept that the
opposite sex and acknowledges your flaw
and they acknowledge that you are a
[__] that's what it is no women are
sensitive
I think you know when another woman you
know is a joke they say oh you're a b or
you know you're a [__] yeah they say
like oh it's candy it's cute and candid
but when a man says it's you you know
like when a guy says to you you don't
look good in those clothes you know he
means that he's not going to say it he's
not going to say it like just to be
horrible if he's telling you oh darling
you're a [__] he means you know what it
is you've kind of been caught because
sometimes I feel like girls will be like
I've done the same friendship group it
means your whole when a man has to open
his mouth and say it honestly for him
because you know men don't care about
stuff men those men only talk when they
need to you're [__] babes I think a
woman a woman's got to maintain that
Social Capital so a man being able to
call her a [__] just diminishes a
social capital because that's that's who
you you're of value to you're not all
value to other girls your value to men
so especially if the guy is the guy that
you like if you see an attractive guy
call your horse game on it's game over
what do you think no I agree honestly
because if a guy came up to me and said
I'm a [__] I'll just I just think my
life to say well I'll never get married
have you seen men or trash before
I've said it before I have said it
before yeah did you mean it no I don't
think all men are trash that's a lie yes
I do
I'm a joy no I think when you're younger
it's easy to be like this and that you
know when you grow up and there's life
experiences life humbles you exactly and
I think you realize everyone's got a bit
of mental health everyone's traumatized
no people need therapy
girls are [__] the same guys and then
they're calling those guys and those men
don't have sex
so then you do you go for a certain type
of woman because you've sat here and
said I'm an international citizen but
then you've said most women are crazy so
you go for crazy women no I I I know
women who are crazy and I experience
crazy women I remember like I said I do
this I talk to women on a regular basis
so I get stories from women who I don't
need to interact with a normal basis and
they will tell me certain things like I
know girls who have stopped their
boyfriend from getting their dream job
because he was going to break up with
her yeah
is that that crazy crazy stuff no don't
you think that major like I think
everybody needs therapy
now I do Advocate foreign
minority of men which means that he has
all the options which also means that
the guys you're calling trash are only
trash because you're all sleeping with
the same men and you want to go around
and say ah men are this and men are that
there's a whole breath of men out there
he will treat you well but you ignore
those ones to sleep with the ones that
your friends your cousin's gonna sleep
with your best friend's gonna sleep with
and the men are trash when really it's
the guys you're letting inside so what
so why why do you think it's okay to say
that just say what big matter of trash
you just said you do think that why do
you think they're trying like I feel
good say the women's side honestly yeah
I feel like my recent experiences have
really opened my eyes Okay and Men of
women from all different walks of life
not that I have slept with them for some
businesses that I've experienced I've
seen married women married men come to
talk to me that seemed that then Happy
relationships I'm like wow so even the
married ones cheat I've seen people that
are my age
um act trash I've seen people that are
traumatized actress people who've been
through therapy at trash I feel like
I've just seen all men act trash so
that's why I say that who cheats more
men or women women don't get caught I
feel like men men cheat more honestly I
feel like mentioning more the rates are
similar maybe yeah yeah and I and I
think women lie more Who Lies more men
or women women
yeah so by that logic wouldn't you say
that women get away with cheating more
yeah no but I feel like for women is
well so so would you say that women are
equally trash
no because I feel like women cheat when
there's a reason men cheat because as
you guys said their hormones make them
cheap so so 20 of men are in sexless
marriages would you say that's a good
reason that if you're not having sex
with your husband that he should cheat
yeah yeah okay so would you say in the
cheating stat is about 25 of a man she
would you say that's a good reason yes
yeah I mean you're young right but I'm
saying like life is gonna show you like
life will humble you and like life at
some point you have to take
accountability for the menu date Okay
and like every every situation you're in
is your own fault like just like
everything like and if you're the common
denominator with all these trash men why
are they interacting with you can I can
I just add majority of the people that
say men are trash one they've never been
raised Maybe by their father have had no
interaction outside of sexual so their
idea of men is just what what can that
man do for me uh in a sexual way and in
a financial way so they will say men are
trash when they don't get sex they don't
get financial gain the the guy the man
resists her her drive for him to do what
she wants so we have to look at these
factors and me personally I've never
said men are trash because I see the
benefits that they bring to my life
family wise friend no honestly I have I
have had no reason to say men are trash
it's a blanket statement when you
appreciate the benefits that men bring
into the arena you actually realize we
need them and they need us and I think
there's a lot of buzzwords that just
come from Tick Tock yeah
um no actually actually
um
men don't need women women need men men
could survive without women if all the
women disappeared tomorrow men would be
fine outside of reproduction
women women need men so they need us for
reproduction yes so that's a full form
yeah if tomorrow they made artificial
wombs what would they need a woman for
eign
men or women
yeah but what's the capacity but what's
the capacity for that companionship you
know outside of children and if you if
he could get a hooker
so men built the world every like all
the hard jobs are done by men if we if
men disappear tomorrow the society would
collapse men built the world that we
complain about yeah but without women
they can't be men they literally can't
you know outside no outside I'm saying
but outside of that what what do they
need women for so I'd say arguably one
of the driving forces for men doing what
they do is women is women I'd say
he's married
with this world for women but then do
you think outside of what I'm saying
what I'm saying is men could survive
without women because men can be alone
women can't women are social beings
we we Thrive we need attention yeah and
men men don't so a man can like live by
himself in the like you don't see women
going out to the woods and just roughing
it that's a man thing you know who's
camping and fishing it's not us
that's true like all the hard jobs are
done by men and and so even so like you
still say things like men are trash it's
so like you're 21 so I'm not like most
girls do at that age it's not I feel
like when they say it correct me from
wrong I feel like when they say it's in
the context of like relationships that's
what she was saying like outside of
relationships when you've got other
males around you Universal brother
father or whatever you appreciate men
anyway just for the other things yeah
but then they'll come and say mental
trash anyway which is a very broad
statement and that's what I'm saying
it's a buzzword they don't mean it
because in their lives they want the men
that they have no no I genuinely think
I'm not saying every girl means it but
like Society paints that even even look
at look at everything on TV it's always
the the dumb Dad what's on The Simpsons
it's everything everything watch
commercials it's always like the guy
doing something stupid the woman coming
to the rescue women are Queens women
empowerment women women there's no men's
empowerment people would laugh yeah but
that's so it disenfranchises men men are
more likely to take risks than women men
put themselves on the line in more
scenarios than women men put themselves
forward physically in the place of a
family it's only because of this society
that we're currently in where they give
it with this full sense of you can be at
the front of the line you can do this
like if there was a scenario where there
was actually danger right now you know
every emotion every man in this room
would naturally make sure that every
woman in this room is absolutely and and
they accept that but then when it comes
to the financial
um the household the work now it's all
about where equals women empowerment we
can do it by ourselves but really we
need each other and that's how it's it's
by a design but I'm saying biologically
yeah I'm saying women men don't need
women outside of reproduction
[Music]
Society has just made us it's true but
this is this is a humbling like stat
that's why people don't like this is a
humbling fact of life and that's why
women don't like to hear it well I don't
I can't because it means we're not as
important as we think we are well I
think that for me I know I can see the
benefits of having men around as a woman
I aim to be a benefit to the men in my
life and if I if I'm not okay I step to
the side and let other people step into
that role I'm not a person that will be
overly both like bolstered up and say I
am this and I'm that but I think in the
way of the world outside of this
societal
um Western mentality
we sit together and we we both add value
we could say oh men could survive on
their own but realistically who wants to